the more contagious delta variant of the
coronavirus has spread across the
philippines bringing the death toll to a
four-month high the country has seen
more than 29 000 deaths and nearly 1.7
million
infections in an attempt to slow the
spread of covid the capital manila has
been placed under the tightest
quarantine curbs as residents fight for
two things they badly need right now a
vaccine and economic assistance
for those struggling to make a living in
manila direct government aid like this
is a lifeline
the pandemic has shattered their
livelihoods
each household is entitled to up to 4
000 pesos or about 68 euros
with the money they hope to survive the
ongoing lockdown
i'll use the cash to buy food for myself
because i live alone
i don't have my own house
and my living space is very
small i work as domestic help and my
daily wage is only 100 pesos
that's just enough for me to eat
since last week manila and several other
cities have been back in lockdown as the
highly contagious delta variant drives a
steep rise in infections
for now residents can only leave home
for essential shopping
some worry the curbs could damage the
fragile economic recovery in the
philippines
every other day we are only allowed to
work every other day
that's why business is bad
fearing even tighter restrictions
thousands have flocked to vaccination
centers like this in the capital
many believed misinformation that
supermarkets would be off limits for
anyone without a jab
since there was panic among the people
because of fake news
our mayor decided to extend the
vaccination until midnight or early
morning
so that people would no longer
congregate in the morning
for others getting a job means greater
health and job security
this is a big help for us working in the
morning
we mingle with a lot of people so this
vaccination is for the safety of
everyone as well
but there's still a way to go on that
road to safety
just 10 of the population has been
vaccinated so
far as the delta variant continues to
search the philippines is digging in for
a protracted battle
we have journalist jc gotinga joining us
jc it's great to have you back on dw
news asia
well it's great to be here thanks for
having me melissa
now you're in manila right now tell us a
bit more about how it feels to be in the
city
well frankly it's tiring it's gotten
tiring people are tired we are now in
the third major lockdown and mind you
we've been in some form of lockdown
since march of last year when the
pandemic began it's just that when the
case loads
stabilize then the government kind of
loosens the restrictions a bit but we've
always been under some form of community
quarantine that's the catchphrase here
and people are tired and especially
because they don't see
much of a new strategy or plan from the
government on how to combat the pandemic
and people are now getting desperate to
get vaccinated of course to protect
themselves and be able to go out and
provide for their families and they're
also desperate for government aid which
doesn't cover everybody it just
includes a segment of the population the
poorer segment of the population and at
twenty dollars per person it doesn't
cover much honestly
so it doesn't sound like a lot of people
would rate the government highly when it
comes to its performance combating the
pandemic
yes um well the the
the general sentiment here is that the
government has done quite poorly
in addressing this pandemic
it has hinged the approach to
vaccination but there are too few
shipments of vaccines coming in and
those vaccines that are on hand well the
rollout is rather slow because there
aren't enough resources and manpower to
be able to open new vaccination centers
so people tend to crowd around whatever
centers are available and then to add to
all that are issues of politics and even
corruption just the other day state
auditors flagged 67 billion pesos or
about 1.5 billion dollars worth of what
they call deficient funds from the
department of health basically what it
means is these funds were either not
spent or were spent but are not
accounted for and they could have gone
to the government's pandemic response
effort it's a huge scandal here in the
philippines now and the government has
not been able to satisfactorily explain
it
now i want to talk about vaccines one of
the things we've seen play out has been
the struggle for developing countries to
obtain vaccines good ones that work
because we know that the chinese
sino-vac and cynofarm once have lower
efficacy rates what is the philippines
using and has it been difficult to get
them
the huge bulk of vaccines available here
is the sign of that one and like you
said there is considerable hesitancy and
reservation as to how effective they are
especially since uh it's assumed that
what's driving this current surge in new
infections is that more virulent delta
variant of the coronavirus uh just to
illustrate that point some people
delayed signing up for the job to wait
for the more reputable brands like
pfizer and moderna to come in and when
they did come in people came out in
droves and lined up causing considerable
chaos in some vaccination centers so
safe to say it's really hard to get a
vaccine here you have to fall under
certain categories either you're a
health worker you're a frontline worker
you're elderly or you are in firm
otherwise you are not even qualified to
sign up for the job yet and even when
you do sign up for one you have to be
you have to wait weeks or even months to
get that call from your local government
to go and line up
sounds very very frustrating jc gotenga
thank you so much for joining us
you